LATE SCRATCH  DUE TO FOR DEFENS
THAT WAS INTENDED FOR REILLY
SMITH.THE  LE.
HE WILL SHOVEL INTO THE CORNER.
BARCLAY GOODROW MOVES IT UP THE
WING.
JONATH
ALONE.
ROBIN LEHNER HAD THE
KILL.
THAT IS OFF THE POST BY ALEXIS
THEY ARE ON S, TRIPPING HIM UP.
GETTING THE FIRST GOAL BY ZAC H
EVGENII DADONOV IS COVERING
DEEP FOR McNABB.
ARIAS, HE SCORES ASKED  POINT
THAT FILIP CHYTIL, GOING
WIDE INTO THE CORNER.
McNABB IS ABLE TO DECENT CAREER
EVGENII DADONOV GOES AGAINST A
FOX.
HERE IS STEPHENSON DRIVIVON,  I
HOT PASS AND HEADS MATTIAS
JANMARK IS SPEED.
THAT WAS S HERE'S SEE TONY.
OPPORTUNITY FROM BARCLAY
GOODROW.
ROBIN LEHNER GOT THE SAVE.
THIS IS A AND HE SCORESGOES RIG
ALEXANDAR GEORORJAD.
HERE THEY COME AGAIN.
EVGENII DADONONO
KREIDER.
THE RANGERS HAD TWO SHOTS ON
NET.
HERE IS STEPHENSON DASHING IT A
THEY ARE BREAKING 2 ON 1.
JONATHAN MARCHESSAULT COMES ,
AND WHITECTIP